okay today's topic
uh johnny depp wins
what did you think when you heard the
news yesterday i was like oh all right
damn how much of the trial did you
follow
uh hey bits and pieces here and there i
was busy i got i had things to do was
that her statement
no i didn't see none of them didn't see
amber statement i saw that they posted
one i didn't
[Laughter]
what happened
let's start
the disappointment i feel today is
beyond words i'm heartbroken
and the mountain of veterans that still
wasn't enough to stand up to the
disproportionate power influence and
sway of my ex-husband
i'm even more disappointed with what his
verdict means for other women it is a
setback
let me keep reading let me keep reading
let me get right let me keep it ready
let me keep reading it please return i
need my audience the act is not done for
we are always on stage
curtains open let us begin
i'm being more disappointed with what
the verdict means for other women ladies
i believe you do you believe me no [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] up out of here
i really feel like that's a little bit a
lot of ladies are like yo
no we don't my husband beat me and they
don't sound like what you went through
okay it is a setback it sets back the
clock to a time when a woman who spoke
up and spoke out spoke up and spoke out
could be publicly shamed and humiliated
it sets back the idea that violence
against
ladies is to be taken seriously
i believe johnny's
attorneys
succeeded in getting the jury to
overlook the key issue of freedom of
speech and ignore the evidence that was
so conclusive that we won in the uk i'm
sad i lost this case but i am sadder
still that i have lost a right
i thought i had as an american to speak
freely and openly
that's so hilarious what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with
freedom of speech ain't got nothing the
problem wasn't that you exercise your
freedom of speech the problem was that
you defamed somebody with lies in lab
okay johnny go ahead tell the world
johnny tell the jury and the people that
i too johnny i'm a victim
tell the world and see who believes you
and the world was like we believe him
i mean believe that hey you know what
hey you did good believe all right
you're really good because you wanted
you wanted us to believe the big deal
you know what the problem was
i think her legal team was really bad
because she should have won this case
she should have it was she should have
won this case i don't know let me let me
tell you some of the stuff that she did
is like she would lie about the littlest
things which then made her whole
testimony not make any sense yeah she
really sat there and tried to convince
everybody that the article that she
wrote about being you know getting
domestic booze wasn't about
her husband johnny depp who she like
been seeing pictures like being hit by
in videos she tried to convince the jury
that if you would have just admitted to
certain things i think people would have
given you a lot more leeway but because
you lied about everything
the three cops who said yeah we didn't
see any injuries on her so the lawyer's
like so what do you think about the fact
that the three cops didn't see any
injuries on you
and then she says no no they did not see
any injuries on me they considered my
face not injured it's not the same thing
and i was like what it was bad i was
like [ __ ]
why are you doing this you were sitting
here in this courtroom when officer
melissa science testified by deposition
about being called to the eastern
columbia building on may 21st 2016.
right i saw her testimony yes and you
heard officer signs testify that she did
not see any injuries on you that night
correct i heard her testify she did not
consider this injured
no
miss officer signs testified that she
met with you and she did not see any
injuries
on your face isn't that correct she did
not consider this injury
officer tyler hadden also testified by
deposition about being called to the
eastern columbia building on may 21 2016
and
he also testified no injuries on your
face on may 21 2016. isn't that correct
they both said that they did not
consider me injured
they did not see injuries on your face
on may 21 2016. isn't that what their
testimony was what their testimony was
is that they did not consider what my
face looked like to be injury they
didn't consider what they walked on in
the house damage but it was
you were sitting here when officer
william gatlin testified by deposition
about being called on
may 21 to the eastern columbia building
and he also did not observe any injuries
on you did he
and that's what he testified to he
didn't even know which one i was
no
i think we all saw on video camera you
identify yourself isn't that correct
i had to because of how far away he was
he didn't even know he didn't even know
who he was after you identified yourself
he looked at you isn't that correct from
a distance yes
and he didn't see any visible injuries
either did he i don't know what he saw
he testified that he didn't see any
visible injuries too i would believe
that he didn't yes
do you think the jury sees that
oh oh thank you for the clarification i
was too stupid was it i thought you were
injured no they considered you not
interested but even even the legal team
said that yeah they said that to one
dude like yeah you want to have your 15
minutes of fame yeah and this
[ __ ] backfired like a champion
excuse me did you know this case is
being televised right i am aware that
there are cameras and so this gets you
your 15 minutes of fame objection your
honor are you meditative
that a question ruled
um
so i stand to gain nothing from this i'm
actually putting myself kind of in a
target of tmz a very litigious
organization
and i'm not seeking any 15 minutes here
though you may you're welcome to
speculate i could say the same thing by
taking amber hurt as a client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly i find that to be purely
logical thank you
yeah yeah when my dude did that i went
like okay this [ __ ] is ready
there were some moments like like i
worked for t like i worked for tmz you
think you're not gonna get at me like i
work for this i work for that i gotta
say the same thing to you about you yeah
taking a client like her whoa
everybody knows that name now no yeah i
think this might be the most high
profile lawyer in terms like a media
case since
johnny cochran oh but this this is
johnny conker this was a and you know
what apparently johnny took this case in
virginia specifically because they allow
for cameras and courts so he wanted this
whole [ __ ] to be televised and
everything to be out there and let me
tell you i would jump in that live
stream and i will say 275
000 people watching at the same time so
with this verdict people were asking
like my thoughts and everything and um
i was surprised by the win not because i
didn't know about the evidence involved
just because i didn't expect amber
hurt's team to put up such a bad defense
so
i was surprised by the way not gonna lie
however
um
and i'm sure for johnny to be able to
get this story out there and get his
side and get it televised and
everybody's watching and everybody's
tuned in i think that's a big deal as
well
um and i think everybody's celebrating
because you know they've seen injustice
in some way shape or form and like good
[ __ ] yeah this is awesome me personally
i think what i struggle with
is that
based off of the lies that she's told
and she's told so many
it ruined his career i do not believe
that you can a get restitution for the
damage that's been done not really all
right and b i don't know if he's going
to get his acting career back
not in the way it was before
i think he is do you think he's going to
be doing triple a movies like pirates of
the community yup why is that i don't
know i think he is because now that's
done that's out there i think the
caribbean is going to take that and
going to be like yeah
you know the issue with that is
once your name is stained it's hard to
come back from that when it's things
with regard to sexual violence you want
to do a follow-up video when it happens
if it happens okay if it happens
if it happens but what evidence do you
have with somebody being accused i don't
have evidence or
or presence i do not have it that's the
difference i understand what you're
saying a hundred percent yes a hundred
percent understanding you're you're
right yeah i'm not disputing that at all
it's very hard to come back from that
that's so that's that's that's
that's a race that you were back in the
field yeah when it started right because
it was so high profiling because there
was 275 000 people watching because it
was all this going on i think he's going
to be able to have it back i think he's
going to be able to be in the media back
where he was and also the fact that it's
not a o.j simpson the guy is likable
right i think there's a disconnect
between what the public wants and what
mainstream does oh right to me i i liken
it to the fact that like so many people
might be for specific political costs
and the vast majority of the public
supports it and politicians don't give a
[ __ ] i understand the way that these
people live in terms of the execs in
hollywood and all this stuff and the way
regular people think is generally very
disconnected i understand but the
difference between between this and that
is that we're talking about money and
what the mainstream wants is money if
the people want and been wanting a
other part of the caribbean and the para
cabins was in the works and stuff like
that they got stopped before because of
that and the people still want it and
people are like get over it we want that
they're gonna do it why
money because now on top of that is not
just parts of the caribbean but it's the
come back of jack sparrow remember that
you cannot beat jack sparrow and amber
heard you almost did what you did [ __ ]
so is that there's now even more money
linked to that okay so now he's back
there's gonna be people that are gonna
be curious he's gonna bring an attention
from that so maybe studios are gonna be
like you know what [ __ ] it let's go
let's risk it i personally don't see any
major studios doing this if it was
something like netflix i might see them
give it a chance but outside of that i
don't see these people wanting to jump
on anything like this they're so safe
with their pr if you make one comment
that's off or you start saying things
that's off they start trying to get
boots you off of things maybe maybe i'm
too jaded about this stuff i've seen it
time and time again where someone gets
accused of something even if the
evidence comes out afterwards they just
don't come back to give that person a
second chance i think johnny will do
movies i think he'll do indie movies i
think he'll do like lower stuff movies
are like kind of artsy movies i just
don't know if i'll ever do the triple a
stuff which hey maybe it doesn't matter
to folks just me personally when i think
of what justice looks like i think you
get back to where you were before that's
what i would ideally like what i think
or what was taken from you can be
restored to some degree i just outside
of the character and the perception from
the public which i think is great don't
get me wrong you love doing something
yeah it gets taken from you yeah
it's hard to feel like things are right
when you can't do the thing that you
love the way that you used to do it and
that's the main it's not even that is
the reason why i think it wouldn't work
is if i was chat huh
johnny at that point if i was johnny and
some [ __ ] happened and i get dropped off
of allegations not even
not even a trial or anything like that
yeah and then you drop me off yeah and
i'm like yo you don't even have my back
the only people that had this back was
dior i believe so you don't even have my
back no more and then you come back and
be like hey
johnny
we spoke to the team and we wanted to do
and i'm like oh now you want this back
yeah now you want this [ __ ] back you
dropped me now you want this [ __ ] back
nah b you're not doing this then then i
understand i understand joni's side
because johnny don't have to do [ __ ] he
doesn't have to do [ __ ] yeah that's why
i would be like you know what
but then again i don't know how
everything
was done how we got dropped what this
conversation was about whatever so it it
all depends of that yeah but i know that
you know you know what happened
for nothing in that industry
how many times have you seen actors
draft for this an opinion that's not
even that spicy no
straight off they don't want any weird
pr they're super sanitary about
everything so i look at johnny i know
how i feel about him most of y'all know
how y'all feel about him and how
positive it is but it doesn't matter to
those folks you get what i'm saying
netflix would take a chance on dave
chappelle and even that was super rocky
for some time it seemed like right look
at his ease on sorry
yeah has he been back he's trying what
did he even do
what did he's even do
he's still dead
think about that think about how crazy
that is think about this think about
that think about this
but that that yeah i understand what
you're saying they're gonna be like that
that that being said
i thought you were stuttering didn't do
that
that being said okay i will say though
on
to your argument if he didn't come back
and did any movie i think the outpouring
of support and how much of a box office
would be would be astronomical the
amount of people who would line up to
[ __ ] support him like it's a
political statement absolutely and so on
that end i think it's fantastic it's
like it's i think it's like what we call
the hotel balancing with all these years
that we had with the you know cancel
this cancel that cancel that cancel that
cancel cancel cancel cancel and he's
being wrongfully canceled i think he's
able to no no we're gonna johnny was not
the one so some people are being
hyperbolic maybe i'm chasing i don't
know maybe some wrong i saw people
saying like oh this is the death of the
me to era and all this other stuff i'mma
be honest with y'all i don't think this
changes much
i really don't
what did we discover today [ __ ] live
sometimes yeah
we've been trying to tell y'all [ __ ]
lie sometimes no no believe all right
i'm like oh my they shut the [ __ ] up
with that [ __ ] do i believe that that
stuff is gonna be gone no no i don't
i really don't i wish i could say
something more
optimistic or things like that i just
don't believe it i've seen too many of
these cases too much of times where like
there's so much evidence that the
person's line and the next case comes
along and everybody jumps on the whole
believe women bandwagon and so i don't
know me parsley i'm not that optimistic
about it but hey i'm open to change i
hope things do improve i just
i just don't believe it will can we
appreciate
you know what people are coming at
ambrose a liar
someone who makes up stuff mind you this
man had his finger partially chopped off
and she has video audio of her beating
him and nobody really sees her as
like a physical like maybe manipulative
no all this other stuff but nobody
really takes her as like oh the male
equivalent of that you know what i'm
saying even with all this
i don't think people really perceive her
that way or talk about her that that's
not been my perception most of the time
we were like yo the [ __ ] is lying which
hey
it's a start
you were saying [ __ ]
uh
when i like
when your exes
your exes drop you and they're like ugh
i'm not gonna come out with you because
you got problems with drugs and stuff
like that and they testify for you and
they're like this [ __ ] never
touched me
when the lady got like
got
fell down the stairs yeah and she's like
no
[ __ ] i fell down the stairs thousand
johnny
i'm not wearing him no i got nothing to
do with that
when your ex when you're my god i mean
some people got good relationship with
their exes it's not that deep okay so
some people got a good relationship with
the parents of the person that is
accused what you mean [ __ ] out of here
even the parents i remember her were
like yeah
she bugging she buggy come on now b
that's a lot of [ __ ] coincidences at
one point at one point you know the
video that came out with johnny and
amber like the video that came out where
she's got the wine bottles and he's like
slapping the cabinets
he's slamming the cabinets and she has a
camera position like right beside the
bottle and then he sees the camera he
says get that [ __ ] out of here right
so they sent a version
to tmz but the first thing they sent to
tmz cut out the part where she's looking
at the camera and smiling and they cut
out the part where she sets up the
camera okay the tmc guy says yeah it was
edited and so the lawyer says to amber
why did you send them an edited version
she's like i didn't send them an end of
the version
this is like why would you why would you
why would you send a version like that
you trying to you edited out portions
that made you look bad before sending it
to tmc
you were very wrong about that so that i
wanted to leave information i could have
done it in a more effective way a lot
sooner and a lot more because i was
living
with this evidence if i wanted to leak
it i could have done a lot more with it
i thought you testified earlier in this
trial that you didn't know how to leak
things i don't
bro
how stupid this man
look
that that's that's that's that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's what you're not eating
you don't know how uh i don't but the
other thing that's the thing the thing
that happened is ego when you touch the
ego
do you know what i did a peacock's gonna
peek off bro it's gonna have to you know
you know how much [ __ ] i got
for forget forgot about what she said
because the ego is stronger nah b like i
got so much gold don't even worry about
it i could have just leaked it yo listen
leaked it bro i'm not i'm the one didn't
you tell me listen you know earlier that
you were not the one uh i'm not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] wow
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
i'm not i'm not the one
let me tell you guys let me tell you
guys let me tell you guys
the real mvp of this case has definitely
got to be amber hurts tears because they
betrayed her so hard this [ __ ] couldn't
summon her tears for nothing she got a
dysfunctional ass pokeball because every
time she tried to i choose you tears
that [ __ ] did not come out no no
she tried crying so many times her face
went
she looks like a japanese meme where the
guy goes yeah yeah that was that one
shout out by the way so let us know what
you guys think we want to hear from you